越早看清楚对于你来说越是幸运，
而不是等你五六十岁了，
恨不得你侄子侄女，
你都拉扯大了，
你才发现他的真面目，
你应该好庆幸啊，
我30来岁的时候，
我孩子还那么小的时候，
我就发现了我和他的关系，
我就发现了本质，
我就发现了他是一个白眼狼，
我就可以及时止损，
我就可以高高的站在这里来俯视你们的表演。
主要是想咨询您一点关于我就是原生家庭的问题，
我先跟你讲一下背景啊，
我这个家庭她是属于一个非常严重的一个重男轻女的家庭，
我妈妈是生了四个女儿和最后第5个终于实现了我弟弟，
我上面有个姐姐，
下面有个妹妹，
身家现在是三个人，
我是16岁就辍学了，
然后出来打工，
也是在北京搞了有十多年，
我现在33，
而且17年中也是运气好了，
我几乎等于实现了财务自由，
那么我是很努力的，
在事业上确实是赚到了些钱，
那在我赚钱的这个过程中，
我必就是说想要来跟我一起干，
因为他之前是在送外卖嘛，
我是很心疼他，
我说送外卖也挺累的，
那你就过来跟我一起干吧，
我就让他进入我的公司，
给了他一个不错的岗位和薪资，
他的工资我肯定是开的有点虚高的，
就如果说普通员工他拿不到这么多钱，
再加上后面他结。
婚生子买房，
我都是出了钱的，
我计算了一下，
我大概是出了有100个，
大家不要觉得这个钱太多，
因为这个钱对我来讲还好，
不算很多哈，
所以说我肯定不是伏地魔的，
我的钱是大多数是我掌控在手里的，
我是已婚已育，
但这个钱都是掌控在我自己手里的。
我之后呢，
我的爸爸和妈妈我一直带在我身边，
虽然说重男轻女，
但我不知道为什么，
我可能是从小被PUA多了吧，
就是老觉得他们可怜或什么的，
这么多年他们出去什么吃喝拉卜，
反正都是我掏的钱，
最近两年他们总是频繁的撕破重男轻女的人掏物质，
比如说从我这里不停的去榨取一点东西给我弟，
他以为我不知道，
可是我知道，
但是我就是不想太计较这些事情，
一直到了今年过完年之后，
你比如说我给我爸买了羽绒服，
我爸都要寄续给我递，
怕他冷着，
就是这样的一个情况，
我很受伤，
就是今年你们都不要来了，
你就在老家吧，
那么他们在老家我涉及到了养老问题，
原来一直说的都是我因为经济好，
我愿意承担1/2，
然后弟弟和姐姐各承担1/4就可以了，
今年我自己突然发现了，
付出再多也没有用，
我说那我就要求就是1/3，
我们三个人平均来养，
他们也都不谈这个养老的问题，
然后就是咱们聊一下，
大家都要装孙子了，
就是说这个总得有人出来牵头来说这个养老的问题那天。
我就在群里发信息嘛，
我就说你们怎么想的，
爸爸妈妈今年不来我这里了，
那他不来我这里，
咱们三个应该是给他养老的，
然后我就提出来给多少钱嘛，
一个老人一年给6000块钱，
一个人是一万二，
我们三个人给到他的话就是3万多块钱。
我姐首先她是不同意，
她的意思是说她从小因为我姐是第一个女孩儿，
是非常不受任何重视的，
我妈把她生下来就放在外婆那里寄养长大，
所以说我姐对我父母是没有感情的，
我姐的意思就是说，
我从小没有在父母身边享受过任何的这个父爱母爱，
我都是在外婆那里长大的，
她的意思就是说我只出一半，
我说姐你出一半，
其实我能理解，
因为确实你没在父母这里享受过任何的东西，
然后这么多年，
我姐为父母出了挺多钱的，
我就同意了嘛，
我说可以，
我和弟弟正常出好，
最恶心的就是这个时候我弟跳出来，
他说那我也要只出一半，
那大姐出一半，
我也只出一半，
我说你凭什么出一半，
你结婚的时候，
爸爸妈妈把所有的存款都拿给你去娶老婆生孩子，
你现在到了养老问题上了，
你说你也要和大姐一样，
只承担1/2，
然后我就非常愤怒嘛，
他就搞那些歪理嘛，
反正总之他就是不想掏这个钱，
我之前在老家的县城为他们买过一套房给父母养老，
当时是花了150万，
这个房我从来没有想过要卖掉它，
但是发生这个事情以后，
我说我为父母。
付出了这么多年，
他们都跟在我的身边，
生活费也好，
吃喝拉撒也好，
都是我来掏，
我没有找你们两个分过一分钱，
现在是因为我实在被你们伤透了心，
我不想再当这个冤大偷，
不想再当这个血包了，
我们三个人每个人出1/3好，
他们都不愿意，
当天就说，
我说我明天就回去，
我就把这套房给卖了，
然后我弟就跳脚了，
他就说，
哎呦，
我还以为你有多孝顺呢，
你也就这样，
我就觉得非常恶心，
那么多年他跟着我连给带发工资，
100多个到他的怀里了，
平时对他也特别好，
他和他老婆吵架什么的，
我给他媳妇儿打钱，
我就说带他媳妇回去跟他过日子，
为了他们的婚姻哈，
付出这么多，
我觉得我对他是非常好的。
这种情况下，
他们说出了这些话，
就是让我一下子很清醒，
我就感觉这么多年竟然是养了一个白眼狼，
就很难受，
我因为我的父母重男轻女，
我知道在我弟一直伪装的很好，
他在我这里这么多年，
我都是就是百分之百的全心全意的对他的，
所以他先赚到钱了，
我现在事业也可努力做，
怎么说呢，
下滑状态吧，
所以说他就不在我这里干了，
因为我带不上他了，
说白了我怎么够自己过来，
现在这个情况，
他钱赚到手了，
反过来他就要咬我一口，
在我这得了这么多好处，
父母的那些钱也都给了他，
最终到养老的情况下呢，
他就开始扯皮了，
他为什么会跳脚，
我觉得他有可能觉得最后这套房会归他，
他有可能觉得。
他回去的时候他有地方住，
因为你住在县城和坐在车里肯定是不一样的嘛，
但是还好我也不是个傻子，
我买这套房子的时候，
我爸就吉利的时候一定要写你妈的名字，
这样他才有安全感，
我说他不需要有安全感，
我需要有安全感，
所以必须写我一个人的名字，
所以这套房子是我个人婚前财产，
我现在我想卖就感，
我已经跟中介联系好了，
我说你尽快给我卖出去，
按照市场价来，
怕地域市场感，
我就是争借口气，
我就必须把它卖了，
反正产权人只有我一个，
你们都做不了主的。
我小时候的零花钱都去捡瓶子，
把捡5毛钱的瓶子卖掉，
去买东西棍，
反正各种的那种您能想到的重男轻女的苦，
我全部都吃过，
但细节就太多了，
但是运气好找到今天了，
确实财务上我是自由了，
我不知道我该怎么去面对将来，
怎么去面对我弟弟这样的人，
我现在是打算不理他了，
我真的很受伤，
我特别能理解你，
我跟你讲啊，
其实你应该庆幸，
我要是你的话，
我大年十五我得放800块钱的鞭炮，
为什么呢？
因为你和你弟弟的关系，
你越早看清楚，
对于你来说越是幸运，
而不是等你五六十岁了，
恨不得你侄子侄女，
你都拉扯大了，
你才发现他的真面目，
你应该好庆幸啊，
我30来岁的时候，
我孩子还那么小的时候，
我就发现了我和他的关系，
我就发现了本质，
我就发现了他是一个白眼狼，
我就可。
可以及时止损，
我就可以高高的站在这里来俯视你们的表演，
这是一件多庆幸的事儿，
明白吗？
而且你那套房子写在你自己的名下太好了，
我要给当年自己的决定点赞，
是不是？
我当年如果是听到他们的这些东西，
我还是写了我妈的名字，
我现在如果想卖，
就是他会配合我吗？
不会，
房产证我放在老家的那套房子里面嘛，
然后我说你们把它给我寄过来，
包括我找不着，
然后我就联系了一个中介公司，
我就把门的密码给他了，
我说今天你就帮我翻就行，
这是我的房子，
那个房产证你一定能找到，
最后就是终于找到给我寄过来了，
我父母的意思还想把这个证给按着不给，
我说你们这不给，
我是产权人，
我还是可以卖。
那几天我一直心里面过不去的，
肯定是对我弟弟很上心，
这么多人真的对他非常好，
王菲姐，
我就觉得我都把心掏给他了，
他老婆和他吵架要跑路了，
我打十万给他老婆，
我说你看在孩子面上跟我弟去货吧，
从小到大我在外面打工，
两千五一个月的时候我都要寄一千五回去，
就是因为我妈经常说你地还小，
家里没你下锅，
说白了，
这个地都是我养大的，
现在反过来在养老问题上这么恶心我，
还要嘲笑我。
他说我还以为你有多孝顺呢，
没想到你还要把这套房子卖掉，
居然还用这种话来恶心我。
我想天呐，
这是人们说出来的话吗？
还是那句话，
姐妹。
啊，
第一庆幸我那么早就发现了这个真实的面貌，
第二庆幸我自己的那套房子写在我自己的名下，
我可以想卖就能卖掉，
卖掉这套房子的这个钱我就把它存下来，
这个钱每年的收益就来作为父母的养老。
至于说我大姐愿意出多少，
弟弟愿意出多少，
这是他们的因果，
这是他们的缘分。
我从此之后不再干预，
不再掌控，
我也不再做一个话事人，
想要一家人去扮演一个团圆的、
包饺子的，
和睦的这样一个家庭，
这个课题放下一面，
放下万般自在，
这是第一个。
第二个事儿，
我跟你说一个更深刻的东西啊，
希望这个能解开你今天的扣。
我以前看那个电视剧老友记，
就是美剧里面有这样一对兄妹，
这对兄妹是同父同母所生，
但她爸爸妈妈特别偏心他的哥哥，
对于他的妹妹忽略打压，
从来没有真正的去为他妹妹的将来去打算，
他妹妹嫁人啊，
嫁妆啊什么的，
本来说准备了，
到时候又卖了，
又买这个买那个了，
反正所有的偏爱都给了他的哥哥，
而妹妹是那个不被偏爱的人，
你以为在这件事情上，
妹妹是那个最受伤害的人吗？
其实。
他不是，
就是那个哥哥，
因为他从小被偏爱，
所以他一直没有成长为一个顶天立地的男人，
一直都在逃避，
遇到任何问题的都在甩锅，
都在找别人的问题，
他没有真真正正成长为一个就是成熟的、
稳定的，
有担当的男人的样子，
这对他来说的话，
也是他的惩罚。
换到你的故事里面一模一样，
因为你不被偏爱，
所以你成长为了一个顶天立地，
有女性，
有力量，
可以给自己幸福，
可以给家庭幸福，
可以给孩子幸福的一个女性的形象。
而你的弟弟，
因为他被偏爱，
所以他一直没有自己承担责任，
一直没有成长，
所以他这一辈子都很难成长为一个顶天立地的男人的形象，
这就是他的惩罚，
他没有办法成长为一个真正的男人，
也没有办法成长为一个可以给他的孩子带来榜样和力量的这样一个父亲的角色，
他这一辈子他都是缺失的，
而你需要做的就是看清这一层，
然后在你的心里做明确的隔离。
明确的隔离是什么意思呢？
在我的心里，
我生的孩子，
我爱的人，
爱我的人，
跟我是一家人，
然后那些不怎么爱我的人，
背叛我的人，
伤害我的人，
白眼狼的人，
他跟我不是一家人，
但我表面上还是客客气气的，
但是不出钱。
嘴钱不出钱，
我跟你说就客客气气的，
不缺钱知道吧，
不是意，
但是我就是客气的，
他们再想要问你要钱的时候就是装穷耐砍，
他不会接受的，
只要你有本事，
你可以离得足够远，
你要说你财务自由了，
你将来不可能去香港生活啊，
不可能换个环境生活，
你想在哪生活就能在哪生活啊，
只要你离得足够远。
同学姐，
你刚才讲的那些说你讲的真的太对了，
以前我也是老想不通，
但是你刚才举了那个例子以后，
我发现你说的真的一模一样，
我弟就是你说的这一种，
太给样之后他的婚姻，
他的家庭也不行，
我弟媳妇带着孩子三天两头就跑路了，
动不动就要离婚了，
全是我给他劝回来的，
拿钱砸出来的，
我不要管啊，
然婆以后对待他们就这样的嘛，
父母养老我凭良心，
我看一年给多少钱，
给多少钱啊，
他俩处不处我不管，
那现在有一个问题是，
我妈身上大概有40~50个都是我给的，
那我还有必要再按年给他养老费吗？
然后我爸身上也给了，
但是她全赌输了，
我觉得你可以装穷啊，
你就说企业亏了嘛，
你把那个房子卖了，
你不要说你是主动生气，
赌气要卖的，
你说我实在没办法，
我这供应商欠了多少钱，
我这个合同亏了多钱，
我这个违约金多少钱，
我得还人家多少钱，
我也没办法，
他们身上的钱足够养老的，
只有我给的钱，
我自己知道，
我妈身上至少有40。
只到50分，
那就先不要再给了啊，
我弟现在给我的感觉是他想从我这里加一点钱给我妈，
最后就我妈把这个钱再给他，
如果说他们再来找我谈这个养老问题，
我不用给了，
因为我已经给了这么多了，
我这里都有转账记录，
你不用这么说，
你说我现在确实困难，
我炒股亏了，
我炒币亏了，
我窟窿太大了，
我都快上黑名单了，
我能反过来再说啊，
就这意思啊，
那我记账了，
希望能解开你心里这个扣，
就是越跑发现其实越幸运，
你才三十几岁你就发现了，
你应该放鞭泡啊，
好的，
好理姐。
还有最后一个问题，
就是因为我的小孩现在还比较小，
两岁多，
然后呢，
我想叫我妈来帮我带把药，
月儿嫂，
哪怕你多换几个，
你多看监控，
你多看多跟踪，
都不要让你妈来再来带了，
好的，
谢谢你，
嗯，
好，
就这样啊，
拜拜，
我看到有个人评论说龙飞啊，
说这个主播也很阴毒，
你只看到了我这么一点点，
你就说我阴毒，
你要看到更全面的我的话，
你们都不知道我到底有多毒，
面对这世间的人是物，
我就是一面镜子，
就是对我善良的人，
我也会很真诚善良的对待你，
但是对我不好的人，
对我歹毒的人，
我可有招儿了，
我特兴奋，
谁能懂我这个点，
但是。
碰到一个不好的人，
一个白眼狼，
欺负别人的善良的人，
我可兴奋了，
我可有招儿对付他了啊，
记得点赞关注哦。